appello a tutti ragazzi venuti valore di
una famiglia e oggi siamo su è più
grazie siamo l'episodio 29 c'è una cosa
ho fatto trenta episodi di è primis
quasi la madonna
il giorno che fa stranissimo a pensarci
con che perché ci sono testi livelli su
matrix altri ragazzi mi avete detto che
hanno fatto un aggiornamento di apple
cioè non ho capito cos'è sta roba
perfetto che va bè ragazzi come cazzo si
fermi che forse forse benvenuto nida se
riesco a prendere gli occhi usarlo come
scudo ganna magagna si appreso libiche
che botta di culo e la partenza ragazze
già capito il senso che prenderà
l'episodio questo è poco ma sicuro
quel vestitino verde tista di merda fa
vincendo lo ha messo nuovo video leggi
interroghiamo folletto subito lega che
cazzo sasso teach a lamentarsi mi dà un
fastidio che non avete idea allora è
pian piano ho detto piano è stata la
cosa più bella della mia vita ragazzi
del livello con più senso che abbia mai
giocato questo è sicuro fanno annunciano
ragazzi e alcolizzato di brutto perché
no e non mi hanno già staccato a precisa
la fermi devo vincere io vinciamo noi
york
adesso fanno ciao raga ma quello si è
fumato qualcosa out aver bevuto sicuro
ai look dai spingi merda di bimbo niente
inferni prova che cazzi certo bravo
bravo la vedi questa mano la vendita in
filo questa ecco ti sta bene che soffre
il lurido soffre a regalargli farla bene
st gara perché il mio dio non è
possibile allora tu sei una palla al
piede agli occhi ho sempre detto ma mio
dio
siamo primi ok la possiamo fare nonno
che mi sta già impegnando quello che la
bici rosa sono così prima ragazzi pole
position pole position è quelli cadono a
caso byyou mai più veloci
poi sì sì bimbo inutile della minkia è
stata una vittoria schiacciante regalare
così adesso in avanti è legato tutti i
ciclisti nel mondo prendo le lanciano i
bambini per vincere era ora
un rock swing decente decenti per
bellissimo bellissimo è stata
l'esperienza più bella della mia vita
no allora non è possibile
si no ma cosa mi sto aggrappando di
preciso non è che affermino che un chilo
provare fermi così credo che ce lo fa
non è possibile ho fatto ho fatto un
acrobazia incredibile sono i siti a
morire come un deficiente questo volevo
dire non solo riuscire a cadere dritto
centra il buco una volta nella tua vita
sì sì sì a dio santo che che chi è che
ansia si può giocare ad happy miss con
un'ansia così però ragazzi non c'entri
buco non sei fatto per questo amico mio
non sei fatto per questo è mai
vai noi ma perché ok ok sono entrato
lusso non chiedetemi non lo so perché
allora vediamo di guidare sta roba bene
così bravo ed i ragazzi non dire non c'è
un volante però sta guida no no no no ma
qualcuno non fanno reis con sarebbe sta
roba che ok ho perso le braccia però io
io ti amo perchè sa che cazzo no no no
non ho neanche preso il traguardo calmi
ok per penso non sono sto bene
uccidi o viene ucciso sta cosa è
bellissima siamo a un anno tutto a posto
sto venendo ucciderti sai ma non fatevi
spiegare che diavolo succede perché non
lo saprei spiegare mi chiamano male mi
sono salvato all'ultimo calmi che gioco
già un po di robe nel culo non so se va
bè moltissimo la via
buongiorno babbo per natale non vorrei
avere tutte ste cose nei cup ranzi
possibile
no no no non riesco neanche più supsi
bene è bella gnocca
puoi vedere il mio di dietro ecco lo
scrive ft questo è l'effetto che mi
fanno le donne ai maxi nuova bonobo
minchia il lancio del babbo
l'ultimo è l'ultimo da me ne frega
niente se fossi così nel culo sì sì sì è
stata è stato un parto certo forbice
sasso cos'hanno fatto che aldo forbice è
più in testa dopo dio sasso sasso carta
emma sinistro si va bene che grazie al
caso lui sa che cosa scelgono e invece e
invece no e invece no strada giusta
facciamo in due su tre dobbiamo arrivare
a 3 la rimonta ci vuole 21 per
normalizzare se vince un'altra volta ha
vinto ho vinto ho vinto 2 a 2
la sua regata ragazzi lo scegliete voi
l'ultimo perché se se perdiamo è colpa
vostra avete tre secondi carta ufficio
sasso voi amici avete letto perfetta la
news life che spero vi ha detto tutti
forbici sono non va bene
foschi fatto giocare che non me lo dire
però è il fight così a prenderci a
cazzotti nario cosa sto facendo quei due
regalano fermi cosa tu faccia stabile
suoni che ha sul suo gatti ho vinto io
ho vinto ho vinto in un so come ho vinto
io non so come però devo ancora li
faccio altro la merda io so già che non
ci arriverò mai al traguardo è una cosa
è certo quanto scommettete ragazzo che
cipro già c'è un pezzo di vetro nel
collo
[Musica]
se ho vinto forse da toccare col quale
si sono attacchi qualcuno ne primis non
vinci non so perché perché si fanno la
gara sui tavoli io so cosa ancora non
l'ho capita il mio dio hanno inventato
le macchine hanno inventato i motorini
di tutto
e voi con i tavoli però vabbè ognuno ha
i suoi modi fate quello che volete che
fatto un salto nella manovra
si no se ho vinto il mio intestino no
però la da lui ha perso cosa sarebbe sta
roba spiegato non mi sono mai commosso
cioè non ho capito ma se io no no cosa
con gli ha preso o no no non perderò 9
dai che questa le batte ufficialmente
tutte io rimarrei così per il resto
della mia vita solo per avere la
soddisfazione di non essere morto
buongiorno si
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma sì ma non è ma dai madama come ha
fatto a prender ma come ha fatto a
prendermi ma io avevo vinto
aversa mi ha sparato in cina e mi
beccano anche in cima purtroppo ho
finalmente un vostro credo che con
questo ne valga la pena almeno oddio
sono con noi non c'è anche che fa un
boltro minchia che potenza ce la posso
fare le carene impossibile guarda che ho
beccato cosa sporca riga verifiche e
vittoria io il mio santissimo come ho
fatto
se sai qualcosa lì che è caduto brook
sarà un dente se sta roba siamo dopo dio
a ragazzi spiega temi che aereo di merda
dovrebbe essere mai questo gesto non
vola non va beh
bello bellissimo eccolo lì perfetto
ragazzi voli low cost ecco cosa succede
a prenderle oddio ma fermi legami la
gara non sono neanche più su sedi la
ciardi però alla fine anche così è una
gara è così che si pilota un aereo lega
forse io ho i miei dubbi però potrebbe
anche essere dove sto andando e lo è lo
ritrovarono su saturno a nostro
scendendo paracadute paracadute
paracadute perfetto va bene lo stesso
perché noi a finire che possono chiudere
qui perchè in teoria sta caricando
livelli miei solo che non so chi cazzo
cioè primis oggi tipo è morto perché
ecco infatti perdere lega non fa niente
stavolta risalto perché non carica una
mafia dunque nero che il video vi sia
piaciuto con che è servito mi è piaciuto
come al solito al suo momento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook che come noi
viene trovata nella descrizione c'era se
la crisi iscrivetevi noi ci divertiamo
il prossimo video è da ragazzi